eine quietschende stradivari ein edles
blasinstrument eine seltene trommeln und
um findet man diese instrumente hier auf
dem wiener naschmarkt bevor das vienna
vegetable orchestra ein konzert gibt
wird erst mal eingekauft frisches gemüse
für den guten klang
kohlrabi kürbis peterlin aus jedem
gemüse kann man ein instrument schnitt
jede pflanze macht ihr ureigenes
geräusch eine entdeckungsreise in eine
welt voller unbekannter klänge und
geräusche
das wiener gemüse orchester das sind
musiker die lust haben am experiment und
tüfteln am risiko elektronisch verstärkt
das quietschen pfeifen reiben schlagen
zu harmonischen klängen und wählten
rhythmen rausch wird
um
jedes konzert ist einmalig denn am
schluss werden die instrumente als suppe
mit dem publikum gemeinsam verspeist
auch die liebe zur musik geht durch den
magen